what's that belief nation welcome to
another YouTube interview I'm really
excited to be here with a new friend of
mine along Kishori this man is the
expert on high performance here's how he
describes himself he is the former
manager of three number one world tennis
players including Novak Djokovic who's I
know a big hear of a lot of people on my
team
he's a high-performance expert who helps
ambitious people belong to the best at
what they do so they can count
themselves to the leaders of their field
Ilan Moulton aboard man Ellen's calling
in from Israel I'm here in in Toronto
we've got a worldwide audience paying
attention I know you focused a lot on
athletes in the past now you're
gravitating towards helping
entrepreneurs what are some of the
things that entrepreneurs need to focus
on in order to get their high
performance mindset out well I think you
know entrepreneurs face a similar
challenge to asset you know if you take
like a hundred meter race the winner is
maybe in milliseconds faster than all
his competitors now does that mean he is
ten times more gifted ten times more
athletic no it means that he prepared
he was smart in the way he prepared yet
he gets all the glory all the fame and
so what is the secret for him to be so
successful as I said he's not he doesn't
work twenty times faster he's uh he's
not 20 times more gifted there's one
secret that makes top performers do
better than everyone else it applies to
entrepreneurs it applies to athletes and
it's the ability to be more focused so
how do we increase our focus then
especially I know it's entrepreneurs
it's tough because we don't have a boss
there's a lot of distractions in our
lives so how do we get that focus yeah
and that's a very good question well
there's different levels first of all of
course the easiest is to say we want to
focus on performing well in the big
moments when we have a big negotiation
when we're brainstorming when we're
doing a big presentation upon a scene
when he's playing the Wimbledon final
tools and techniques how to do that we
can talk about that later on but in
order to perform your best under
pressure you need to practice and
prepare so an athlete does work Anders
Ericsson cause deliberate practice and
entrepreneurs can do the same whereby we
we work on high-value activities and we
also work on improving our specific
skills and the way we do that is by
dedicating time for those tasks I call
them
power blocks blocks of time where we do
nothing else whether it's one hour or
two hours or ideally even three or four
hours this is how we train our man to
become more focused and that's that's
like one level if you do that you're
already ahead of the curve if you want
to take things further then you want to
focus on creating the kind of lifestyle
that helps you feel energized focused
inspired motivated and I'll give you
just a story from the world of sport no
hot chocolate like when he was 14 he was
a top he was a good junior player but
not like people didn't think is the next
Federer or nada
he himself he always believed that he'll
be the next world number one and he
worked hard he trained I did everything
right he managed to become 3 in the
world which already exceeded the
expectations of most people but then he
hit a ceiling maybe because the guys in
front of them were Federer and Nadal and
like whatever he did he just wasn't able
to consistently beat them or win many
Grand Slams and then when he lost the US
Open final in 2010 he was so frustrated
so he asked himself what's the next step
and he realized the next step is to
focus on becoming the fittest tennis
player in the world but here's the
important thing you didn't only focus on
becoming fitter than his competitors he
focused on eating right sleeping right
meditating hanging out with the right
people in the in other words if you want
to become a top performer it's a
lifestyle and that doesn't mean your
life becomes like a slave actually it
probably means you have more free time
to do the things you really enjoy
because you'll be working smarter not
necessary
harder got it so for that power blocking
if it's 1 hour 2 hour 3 hour is that
when we are focused on getting good at
what we're doing improving our craft or
is that we're focused on mindset or or
meditation or something that's outside
the actual skills we need to build it's
one of two things either building the
skills that will take you to the next
level in your business or in whatever
you want to achieve or working on very
high-value tasks you see we always one
big obstacle in our businesses
it's distractions and why do we love
getting distracted in my view we love
getting distracted because they actually
give us a good excuse not to do the
difficult things the challenging things
are saying the needle movers of our
business so we do busy work we're
answering emails were and many meetings
we feel like we're working very hard but
we're not actually moving our business
forward
so is a suggestion then to every single
day in your calendar block off at least
one hour and in that hour whether we
call it you know entrepreneur time or
power time or CEO time that's when we're
focused on doing a project is actually
gonna help us grow forward as an
entrepreneur like this it's a 50 minute
I mean the time range of different
people have different preferences for me
it's 50 minutes 55 minutes actually
whereas switch off my phone I have no
emails I work on a specific task that I
defined the night before and and once
you manage 50 minutes maybe you you try
a 10 minute break or a 5 minute break
you relax you you take a walk you drink
some water and you do another one if you
do to power blocks within 120 minutes
and you do that early in the morning
your productivity will skyrocket
and the beautiful thing you actually
train yourself to become more focus then
there isn't them to fine-tune your
science showed us that like and we can
actually change the structure of our
brain by focus on focusing on specific
things and you may have heard of the
study with London taxi drivers you know
that study
so London to be a taxi driver you need
to learn all the streets off by heart to
be a black cab driver so they took fMRI
pictures of taxi drivers before they
took that course and then they took a
brain scans after that course and the
part responsible for the memory called
the hippocampus actually became bigger I
loved it action items for entrepreneurs
everybody watching live and on the
replay block off as a first chunk 55
minutes for tomorrow in your calendar
for some big project work you're gonna
do and then tonight figure out what
you're gonna do in that 55 minute so
that you don't get distracted you know
what you're gonna do I'm at the center
not similar to an athlete who trains
consistently and deliberate practice
this is another concept that I think are
the preneur can really benefit from
deliberate practice is when you have for
example a coach who decides we're going
to work on a specific skill that a
player is struggling with he challenges
his hism his student but he doesn't he
challenges him so it's not over
challenge but it it is very very
difficult work and he monitors his
progress he gives them feedback and you
do this on a consistent basis so as an
entrepreneur I personally believe we
need to have our own schedule for
learning we need to we need to know what
other areas we want to get better if you
want to create a podcast you need to be
good at interviewing you need to know
the technology you need to know how to
build relationships these are skills
that we can actively learn got it so
here I want to get your perspective on
this this is a personal viewpoint of
mine so be great to hear what you have
to think around health a lot of people
when they're going on a diet the experts
say get rid of any junk food in your in
your condo in your apartment in your
home so you're not tempted to to eat the
junk food my perspective on that has
always been I think I think that
actually makes you weaker when I go on a
diet
I like having like a big thing Oreos
right in front of me just to show myself
that I can that I'm strong enough I like
having the like the temptation right
there just to build the mental toughness
what are your thoughts on somebody who's
trying to make a change and they have
these distractions is it is it get rid
of them completely change your
environment or learn the toughness to
kind of get through it and at what level
you are with regards to building your
habits you see like initially our
willpower is like a muscle that has
limited resources and if you if you over
use willpower in one area you will
struggle in another area so let's say
you're on a diet and you really force
yourself not to eat chocolate
you see chocolate all day then maybe in
the evening you'll be so exhausted and
so tired you just spend three hours
watching TV so then it's counter
intuitive on the other hand I really do
believe that we become tougher through
resistance training so if you see
chocolate you can tell yourself I'm not
going to eat it if you can even give
yourself a purpose while you're not
going to eat it because my health my
well-being but being energized around my
kids my work is much bigger than this
little piece of chocolate then that's
fantastic so you know how I treat myself
to get control over this device might
form I have on line blocks when I check
my phone for emails and messages when I
want to check my phone in between unless
it's really super urgent I wait for five
minutes before checking email and these
five minutes really teach me not to
react on impulse but rather like rather
has the power and the choice to decide
what it is I want to do I love it now
now Elan has a special bonus everybody
who's watching live and in the replay
around mental toughness is a there's a
free ebook that he's created if you
check out the link you can go download
it this kind of ties in mental toughness
why is it important how do we develop it
I know it's in the PDF ebook and people
can go and get but can you just talk
quickly about it well I think you know
coming from the world of sport what
distinguishes the top tennis cares from
everyone else any chemist they don't
know how to hit four
I can't first and then it is mental
toughness the ability to perform on
command the ability to create habits
that will transform our lives and the
way we develop mental toughness is we
start slowly and we build new habits
that will really empower us gradually
and maybe you heard of the metaphor with
the one penny that doubles every day
like if I were to offer you three
million dollars now or any doubles every
day for 10 days what would you pick yeah
I want the penny you wouldn't
definitely dog because you'd have $5
instead of 3 million but what would you
pick the pen or the 3.3 million dollars
okay you pick the penny how many days 30
days five million dollars small little
effort on a consistent basis eventually
compound to something massively huge
right and what I think is really
important for people to understand just
changed my life this single piece of
advice but on the one hand we
underestimate our abilities in the long
run like we we don't even know what
we're capable of and within ten years or
five years we can move mountains on the
other hand we overestimate ourselves in
the short run we think we can do bigger
things in a week or in a month and we're
actually able to do it 100% agree
so guys you can check out that link in
the description the free book on mental
toughness I want to move it over to the
live chat we've got a whole bunch of
people tuning in asking questions let's
see how we can help provide some value
first up is GB talking about I have an
idea for a website but I'm not doing it
because I'm always lazy how do I
overcome my laziness
well laziness is an interesting
phenomena because you need to understand
that our brain has a few functions one
is to survive one is to experience a lot
of pleasure pleasure
and one is to optimize our lives like
two
things as simple as possible so being a
lazy Riemann's staying in our comfort
zone and that is often not a bad thing
however if you want to grow if you want
to progress in your life you need to
start pushing yourself slowly and
gradually and I would do it by taking
one little activity that can change your
life and so this same design website
that you want to launch whatever it is
block one hour a day and do a power
block spent 50 minutes only on this
activity do it first thing every morning
6 to 7 or 7 to 8 the only task that you
deal with is this single project and
you'll see and no time you'll have it up
and running and you recommend doing that
like first thing that power block make
that the first thing you do in the
morning I have my morning routine but I
try and do a power block before my wife
and kids wake up and when I do manage to
do a power block my day looks completely
different because I did a high-value
activity but it's really crucial for
whatever I'm trying to achieve and it
just makes me feel so good and it takes
all the pressure away for the rest of
the day the opposite of doing a power
block is checking your emails and the
problem with that is you don't know what
kind of emails you're gonna get you
might get um great news you might get
bad news you might get all sorts of
annoying tasks and you don't you wanna
have a power block done before you get
into that cycle love it so you wake up
morning routine then your power block
then family and rest of the day
yeah then throughout the base they'll
have a 2/3 more power blocks bit of work
I try and finish work by for between 4
and 5 o'clock and then it's only family
time and sometimes like not now my life
is a bit upside down because I have a
new three-month-old baby I have three
your kids well write anything in the
world
I'm I haven't noticed wake up at 4:30
a.m. I love that and then I get to do up
until like two hours of work before my
family wakes up now kids sometimes wakes
up in the night so so it's on a random
basis like I do always get out before
like 6:00
right does that for those of you who are
an Instagram Ilan's got this great
picture of him and his new kid and
they're both falling asleep in bed
super cute picture that you guys can go
follow him and check it out it's the
cutest thing you know as an entrepreneur
we want to have time for our family we
want to have time to have fun because in
the end what all the money and all the
success worth if we don't live it also
less love it I love it
okay next Amanda is writing in how do
you transition from being an athlete to
an entrepreneur as a former NFL
cheerleader I'm now working on moving
into my own States as an entrepreneur
any advice for the transition you have a
few character traits that can help you
regardless of what you want to do I
think the number one trait that you need
to incorporate is patient you need to
you know you were performing at this top
level and when you start in something
you you need to have you need to accept
that you're a beginner and you need to
accept that growth learning mindset and
then if you are applying that skill of
deliberate practice that that skill that
helped you become a top athlete in
entrepreneurship then that will really
help you and then of course what does
every top athlete have that happen every
entrepreneur who can afford it should
have as well it's a good coach find
someone who's like two three steps ahead
of where you want to be and let them
guide you through the steps that you
need to take let them hold you
accountable let them push you and I
think I think you achieve whatever you
want to achieve why do you think
athletes have such a hard time
transitioning I mean they have the
dedication they work you know they are
used to building up a team they're used
to work with coaches but so few of them
actually go off to then make him a
successful career as an entrepreneur
what's what's the problem other
different problems one of that you know
some people they they think if they're
great in one area you know they imagine
you're like a world number one tennis
player or football or whatever everyone
looks up to you so suddenly you think
you're you're and
you're just great wherever you do and so
you have this overconfidence that like
it would be easy for me to start a
business to create a restaurant whatever
and and they forget the need to embrace
the struggle to fight their kids to work
really hard I think they were so hard
all their life now it should come easy
and it doesn't work that way the other
thing is very few people get education
on key areas like for example money they
don't get taught like how to deal with
money how to invest money how to save
money how to how to how to do the key
element of building up a business the
leather final thing is I think I think
beliefs also play a big role you know
like athletes spend a lot of time to to
work hard on a growth to train their
inner game to really visualize a lot of
athletes visualize their goals and they
really transform their mental trauma
start of water capable of doing and I
think we need to do the same for any
other project we need to take it as
seriously as a sports school st is
saying how do i force myself I find it
that I'm very productive but I can't get
myself up unless I have something
essential to do like work how to get up
early in the morning yeah force yourself
to wake up early you need to live a life
that you feel excited about you know the
snooze button yes sorry yes in a way an
attempt to delay your life you know it's
like I don't feel like getting up like
my life isn't that exciting you need to
live an exciting life and how do you how
do you train yourself to have an
exciting life when you get up you need
to prime yourself so example by asking
yourself questions like what's one thing
that I feel super excited about in it or
who could I surprise and make happy
today for example your wife or your kids
or your friends
and doing creating a trigger to these
questions like I've created a trigger
that every time I hit the shower I ask
myself what is one thing I feel super
excited about and I have to tell you I
used to be this bachelor party animal
who went to clubs for 5:00 in the
morning I woke up at 11 in the morning
and ever since I wake up early in the
morning my life has transformed I feel
more energized I feel more rested I get
so much done in the morning that I have
to have to move free to do whatever
actually used so it is a lifestyle
switch it takes time you know if if
you're used to staying in bed anymore in
the mornings then it will take effort to
get out of that habit but the reward is
so worth it I think this news button is
also an identity thing where you set a
goal to wake up at a certain time the
next morning and the first thing you do
is say I'm not gonna hit my goal and
that's okay hundred it's such a good
metaphor yeah
cool Frank is writing in awesome
information I believe we put ourselves
in a box how can we break free so this
is kind of mindset stuff how do you
break through the box you put yourself
in how do you even know that you're in a
box well first of all you know you're in
a box by becoming more aware cognitive
dissonance is one of the biggest
problems we have we all have these blind
spots you know when we have goals and
fortune and image but we act
inconsistently with them then we'll try
and justify them unless we become aware
of of that happening and I think the
biggest secret you know like you'll hear
people always talk about you know how do
we get out of our comfort zone and and
it's not an easy process you know it
takes effort it takes time it takes
support but I think the secret to it is
really just accepting that we're human
accepting that doing mistakes is part of
the game and really having this learning
mindset like doing things not for the
results initially but for the process of
getting feedback of getting better or
building a cat
two traits that we want to build if we
do that then it becomes so much easier
to push ourselves and to challenge
ourselves do you have a process for
making that mindset shift stick because
for so many people they're around other
people who are complaining and blaming
the government and think failures is
really negative thing and like that's
their that's their daily environment how
do you so for people watching and say
wow I agree this is great 100% and then
they're on fire for the rest of the day
they wake up tomorrow and the mindset is
gone how do we make that mindset shift
consistent very simple beginning you
listen to a podcast like your podcast on
a daily consistent basis and you feed
your mind with this information so long
I'm so off until it clicks in your head
because in the beginning of information
that you don't fully digest but you
don't know who it will be and when it
will be that you hear this message and
some you say you know what this is so
true and it changes my life and any
advice I got you know I probably heard
10 times before and it's it's quite
random why decided to make it change at
porn it's another plot point why but
what I've always done is I've exposed
myself with the kind of information that
I think will change my life got it and
do you recommend putting that in your
morning routine or is that is that a
power block or is that at the end of the
night like how do you when do you do
this stuff so I try to read a book a
week like this over two weeks and I have
a reading block schedule every day but
for podcasts what I love to do oh for
online courses I love listening to them
in my car I turned my car into my
driving library and then when I come
home in the morning or in the evening or
whatever I read some notes just like
hundreds of these books with all sorts
of notes that I was with youth but
that's what I would do you know when you
commute or you spend time in the car
even in the gym depending on what you do
is you go running on the beach or
whatever those are moments where you can
really learn and you know also not
necessarily you know when you listen to
a podcast I don't aim to learn
everything but I hear I just I just
embrace the method I just integrated
into my being that makes sense
right for someone who maybe works at
home and doesn't commute every morning
is it worth forcing that time and spend
half an hour in the morning listening to
a podcast or watching YouTube videos or
do you recommend it just says when you
have downtime listen to YouTube video I
definitely recommend whether you book a
time at home or you take your earphones
and you go for a walk or you change them
you doesn't even sit in a coffee shop
with your headphones I think it's very
individual I definitely recommend anyone
sitting at home at least to take one
longer walk today I also recommend that
you go to the gym where you make some
kind of scene change but I guess I guess
it's individual and if you like
discipline if you really realize that
you're procrastinating a lot at home
made it could make sense to go to like a
shared working place or an environment
where you see other people work as well
Vijay's writing to say how do you avoid
stress and tension hmm this is a good
question first of all stress and tension
is not the enemy right chronic stress
and tension of the enemy now how do you
really become a topless one where you
mix two things on the one hand you do
challenging things that push your outer
limit on the other hand you prioritize
recovery and you do recovery in
different layers the first one is if you
do power blocks we talked about them
then between every power block you do a
10-minute break where you go for a walk
you do a bit of stretching you close
your eyes you eat something healthy you
do whatever it takes you don't do
browser and you don't check your emails
because that's that's like
counterproductive recovery then after 2
or 3 power blocks you do a longer break
ideally you you probably shouldn't do
more than 4 or 5 power locks because if
you mM Brad you're given a hundred
twenty percent of your energy so they're
quite exhausting then you recover in the
evenings I try and stop working at 5
p.m. then it's downtime
we plan trainers time doing fun things
going to the gym then you also
prioritize sleep you know you really you
make sleep your Holy Grail and there's
different things you can do you know I
try and tune down an hour before I go to
death I try and go to sleep at the same
time every evening more or less as
possible this is on a daily basis the
second layer is on a weekly basis I
recommend at least one day where you do
nothing work-related ideally no emails
and I know that sounds scary but you
just really allow your mind to switch
off from your work and then on a third
layer ideal you take a vacation every
three months and it doesn't mean going
to the Bahamas every month or whatever
you can do a staycation at home you can
go somewhere close by but just taking
three or four days off to completely
recharge your batteries I love it on a
similar note people are asking how many
power blocks did we have per week so I
try on a good day to do 3 to 4 power
blocks worth 55 minutes I do that five
times a week so it comes to about 20
power blocks at most for me but these
are really high value activities and
then if you do your recovery right then
like you should really you should really
feel that you're doing the kind of
activities that can transform your
business and on recovery I want to give
another metaphor to the world of sports
the number one expert in recovery in my
opinion is Roger Federer the year and I
have to go you know I think was 34 years
old he took six months off basically a
sabbatical he had some injuries but he
also just wanted to get back into his
freshest most energized state he came
back he he performed as good even better
than before if you look at her schedule
she doesn't play too much she takes long
breaks in between some of the bigger
tournaments and he just does everything
right and the reward is that he has the
longest most sustainable
career and that's that's the goal for
all of us we want sustainable success we
don't want to turn out after a year or
two years and for those three power
clocks that you're doing any money every
day you're yeah I I planned them in 94
and I also had like a strategic planning
session every week well take my diary I
can look at my monthly and uni goals I
think about how my last week went I
think about what went well what didn't
go well what do I want to do better for
the upcoming week what's my main goal
for upcoming week and then I literally
schedule my power blocs
I love it Salima is just asking a
follow-up question how do you prevent
overwhelm with all the tasks that have
to get done
well overwhelm means that you're doing
too many things at once so the first
step is you need to decide what are the
two three most important goals right now
that you're working on and then create a
plan to complete those goals and I mean
goals not only in business it can be one
or two business goals one or two
personal goals but if you if you have
like ten goals that you're working on at
the same time you feel overwhelmed you
probably won't complete anything fully
and it's a bad cycle it's better to work
at one thing at a time and get the
confidence of completing the things that
you really want to do I love it
it's it's crazy how quickly time flies
when you're having fun in a good
interview I mean it's still tons of
questions people coming in guys if you
want to learn more about Elan you could
check him on his website also there's
the free guide to mental toughness that
we've linked up in the description below
do you have a final message that you
want to share with my audience on mental
toughness or high performance yes
absolutely we're on this world to live
an awesome life so do whatever it takes
whether it means power blocks whether
waking up ready but don't just settle
for where you are go for more I love it
I love it
well thank you so much for taking the
time to join us all the way from Israel
thank you guys for watching and asking
someone a great questions we'll see you
again
soon on another episode I believe in you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and we'll see
you soon my world no it's just my
typical Extro for people but sure that's
great what's a LAN in one word what's
your most important core value I think
it would have to be love love I like it
like it well on that note thank you guys
everybody for watching and we'll see you
soon